Hello and welcome to fire of learning.
Warren Buffet,
born in Omaha,
Nebraska.
August 30th,
1930 is an American investor,
businessmen and philanthropist with a net worth of 82 point $9 billion.
He is a third richest person in the world.
In this video we will discuss 10 tips and pieces of advice bup it has left us
which he has utilized and achieving his accomplishments and furthermore,
which display his mentality.
So let's get into it.
Number 10 someone is sitting in the shade today because someone else planted a
tree a long time ago.
This is a good quote to start with because this is very much how Warren Buffet
thinks.
A defining feature of his mentality is that he is a long term thinker.
Often we are caught up in the short term trying to have instant reward and
gratification when ultimately the things in which we invest in the long run may
be the most profitable.
Number nine it takes 20 years to build a reputation and five minutes to ruin it.
This is something which is important to remember.
No matter what field you're in,
it can take years to build up a reputation of being honest,
respectable,
and trustworthy,
etc. However,
one dishonest or unscrupulous mistake and your reputation maybe lost.
Number Eight,
predicting rain doesn't count.
Building Arcs does.
There are a lot of people who claim to have seen economic or political or social
changes coming in the future,
both good and bad,
but having seen a sudden change coming is ultimately unimportant if you have not
prepared for it.
Number seven risk comes from not knowing what you're doing.
This quote can be taken a couple of ways.
Firstly,
the less you know the greater risk in which we'll find herself and your
endeavors in general.
Secondly,
there are many risks we have to take in life and their risks because we don't
know what the outcome will be.
We can't possibly,
regardless in the end,
the greatest risk in life may be not taking any risk at all.
Number six,
chains of habit are too light to be felt until they are too heavy to be broken.
Buffet has spoken regularly about the importance of developing healthy and
positive habits early on in life because the longer they persist,
the harder they are to break.
We may not notice how bad smoking is until we have to quit,
at which point it's significantly harder.
We may not understand how important it is to exercise until we suffer from a
lack of it.
We may not understand the value of money until we have very little,
et cetera.
It's important to introspect and and plan your life now,
not later.
Number five,
in the business world,
the rear view mirror is always clearer than the windshield.
This is obviously above its own way of saying hindsight is 2020 we don't exactly
know what the future may hold.
However,
despite the risk of failure,
we still have to keep moving forward and not focus on what is behind us.
Number four,
should you find yourself in a chronically leaking vote.
Energy devoted to changing vessels is likely to be more productive than energy
devoted to patching leaks.
This is important not only in business and investing,
but in life in general.
Now,
buffet isn't saying you should give up when things go wrong.
Maybe that's the case with investing in the stock market,
but when things are going terribly wrong,
sometimes it is better in life to get up from it and try something new or move
on to a new focus or a new ship.
Number three,
if you get to my age in life and nobody thinks well of you,
I don't care how big your bank account is,
your life is a disaster.
Perhaps this is easy to say if you're sitting on billions of dollars,
but regardless,
despite everything buffet has achieved in his life,
he still believes that in the end it is not material wealth,
but the depth of your relationships with others that counts and gives meaning to
your life.
Number two,
the best thing I did was to choose the right heroes.
While we shouldn't try to live our lives like other people,
searching for inspiration and heroes is completely normal and according to
buffet,
a great idea.
If you're going for something great heating the wisdom of others who have done
great things with for you is always a wise move.
Number one.
Rule number one,
never lose money.
Rule number two,
never forget.
Rule number one,
this,
as you can see in buckets,
own words,
is rule number one when dealing with investment and business in general,
and that quote is about as straightforward as it gets.
These were some of Buffett's highlighted quotes.
However,
he of course has much more to say and I encourage you to look more into them.
For more videos like this and videos on many other subjects,
be sure,
take out fire of learning and subscribe.
Thank you for watching.